[Music]
there are many different entities that
appear in Norse and Germanic folklore
and today we'll be discussing the owner
what many consider to be the race of
giants and although that may be correct
for some Yona not every yotan is a giant
the word yotan or yacht nur if are
referring to more than just one came
from the old norse third or third sir
which came from a proto-germanic word
meaning to consume or to devour now as
for the assumption that every yotan is a
giant that story is quite long and spans
across numerous cultures so I'll try and
summarize it as best I can the word that
we use today in English to refer to a
giant comes from the French Azure which
became part of the English language in
the year 1066 BCE when William the
Conqueror took control of England
the French word Jian refers to the
Giants of Greek mythology and we know
they didn't have the best relationship
with their deities so as it possible
there was a comparison drawn between the
Giants of Greek mythology and the Yoda
of Norse mythology based on the fact
that some of them were giant in size and
hated their respected deities well yeah
it's entirely possible that that may
have caused some confusion so if you are
someone who genuinely gets upset about
the yotan are being referred to as
Giants then you can blame the ancient
Greeks the French the British the Marvel
Universe and the new God of War a lot of
people to be angrier so if the Ahtna
aren't the same as Giants but they
aren't quite gods then what exactly are
they what makes a yotan a yotan that in
itself is a difficult question to answer
simply the first being to exist after
the creation of the universe was the
giant Amir the father of giants who also
happens to be a yotan so the Yona are
technically the first race of Norse
mythology the first God to appear was
bawdy the grandfather of Odin
now during this period the owner and the
gods lived in harmony and the race is
married and had children together
bori had a son named board who then
married bestia a yotan so Odin and his
two brothers are in fact part yotan and
the exact percentage we don't really
know because the circumstances
surrounding the birth of board are very
ambiguous
but if we assume that Bor was 100% God
then Odin and his siblings are at the
very least 50% yotan this is important
because Odin had many children from many
different mothers and that would make
all of them party Odin if we take a look
at the most famous example Thor his
mother was a yotan woman which of course
would make Thor 75% or three-quarters
yotan which is quite ironic for reasons
we'll discuss a bit later the point I'm
trying to make here is that Thor and
Odin are perhaps the most famous gods
that come from Norse mythology and Odin
is only half God while Thor is actually
more yotan than God so when did this
conflicts between God and yotan begin as
tensions grew between the two races it
would be the actions of Odin and his two
brothers
Vili and they that would change the
dynamic of the cosmos forever the three
brothers would then slay Amir and from
his body much of the cosmos and the
Norse world was created this is why we
rarely distinguish between God and yotan
and even between the gods themselves the
three brothers were considered the first
of the ICA tribe despite all those that
came before them in a way that was quite
similar to what we see with the
Olympians who were granted their title
because they rebelled against their
ancestors with the nine worlds and much
of the north cosmos now formed the split
between God and Yona began those who
followed Odin and his brothers would
then make Asgard their new home the
odhner who disagreed of Odin would then
make their home in Jotunheim a vast
unforgiving and inhospitable land where
winter never ceases this description of
a harsh icy wasteland could definitely
be another reason
why some believed all yet no to be frost
giants in reality the Ahtna are quite a
versatile race some of them are indeed
giant in size but some of them can also
alter the way they look
Loki being the most famous example
transforming into several different
animals and objects they can also be
described as extremely ugly or like the
giant s scardy they can be described as
extremely beautiful so if they don't
always resemble Giants and they have
similar supernatural abilities to the
Norse deities then how do we really
distinguish between them appearance is
evidently quite misleading because at
first glance you'd assume Odin Thor and
Loki to be just gods but technically
you'd be wrong about all three one of
the main beliefs in the differences
between them was that the yoader were
never worshiped in the same way that the
eye sear and the veneer were this may
have been true for certain periods in
time but we know that scardy was
worshipped by the Vikings and even today
has become part of some neo-pagan istic
circles so the owner not being
worshipped wasn't and isn't always the
case the simplest way to distinguish
between the two is in the way they
behave and what they represent it's
fairly common for the yoader to be shown
as chaotic and destructive forces but
what they really represent is the period
of chaos before creation if we go back
to the first ever being created
Ahmir he was born when the fires of
Muspelheim met the ice of nifflheim in
the chaos that led to it maybe in slain
we then have the creation of the cosmos
from his decaying body we also have
Ragnarok which symbolizes the eternal
struggle between God and yotan the owner
wanting to sink the world into chaos to
create a new one and the gods wanted to
contain them and prevent this from ever
happening with Ragnarok in this final
chaotic a battle the world is not
destroyed it's essentially reborn this
can be interpreted as the owner finally
avenging the Fallen Emir
or it can be seen as the cycle that
began with the death of Amir finally
coming to an end only for a new one to
begin this unruly nature is why
Jotunheim is also at times referred to
as aught guard which roughly means
beyond the fence those inside the fence
are considered law-abiding individuals
and those outside are chaotic and
untamed which is why at times you may
see the preface of odd guard before a yo
teens name this is also why the gods
built a wall around Asgard to stop the
owner and other enemies invading now not
every yotan is seen as a destructive
force but that is what most represent
and personify so let's begin with the
most famous yotan who also happens to be
the biggest enemy of the owner
everybody's favorite angry hammer
wielding jinn German Thor as we
mentioned earlier Thor was 75% or
three-quarters yotan but that certainly
didn't mean he felt any compassion
whatsoever towards his kin Thor was one
of the primary protectors of asgard and
midgard wherever the yote Noah cause in
trouble
Thor was there to put it into it one of
my favorite stories is when the Thor's
hammer was stolen after asking around
loki discovered that the hammer was in
fact stolen by Thrym the king of
Jotunheim who had only trade the hammer
if he was given the goddess Freyja as a
bride as the main defender as Gaunt
thorns have immune a course and a
serious concern after a long discussion
Heimdall offered the idea of Thor
dressing up as Freya in order to trick
the yotan King Thor reluctantly accepted
this plan and along with Loki dressed as
he's Maiden they then traveled to
Jotunheim eventually after some
persuasion from Loki the King accepted
his new bride and presented her with the
stolen hammer Thor of course pounced
this opportunity taken me on air and
killing every yotan in sight
another interesting story involves the
giant known as guy rod one day loki had
transformed himself into a falcon and
flew over guy rods castle but the giant
noticing that this was no ordinary bird
captured loki he then locked him in a
cage you have no food until he revealed
himself he then made a deal to let loki
go if he also bring thor to his castle
without his hammer when loki returned he
told thor of the giants eagerness to
meet him he also told him that he had
two extremely beautiful daughters thor
unable to resist left his hammer behind
and followed loki to the castle before
reaching the castle they decided to rest
in the home of the giant s breather who
warned thor of the giant he was about to
meet and given him a magical staff and a
belt in the process thor and loki set
off the next morning but when they came
to the river vemma one of guy rods
daughters tried to drown thor but by
using the staff given to him thor and
loki were able to escape and chase the
Giants s off by throwing rocks at her
when they did finally arrive at the
castle thor was taken into a room with a
chair which he fell asleep in weary from
his travelling the sisters then lifted
this chair and tried to push it up
against the ceiling to squash Thor but
Thor would push up against the ceiling
and put all of his weight down onto the
chair breaking the backs of both the
sisters and crushing them he then
confronted guy rod after all he was a
guest and his hosts had done nothing but
tried to kill him the giant had no
interest in thoughts concerns and
instead threw a lump of molten iron in
his direction
Thor however caught this lump of iron
and threw it back in the direction that
it came from the ball of iron then hit
guy rods square in the head and killed
him immediately Thor also killed crow
near the fiercest yotan of all it's
quite obvious a thorny owner didn't see
eye to eye and there are many stories of
conflict between them sometimes they
outsmart Thor and other times they just
die normally the result of a hammer or
some kind of objects being thrown at
them
a name I've mentioned a few times in
this video is the yotan or the giant s
known as scar d she's often described as
a beautiful Huntress and her
relationship to the gods is fairly
neutral if not rather friendly another
yotan we can't really forget about is
Loki now you can describe Loki as a
destructive yotan but I think his tricks
alike mentality makes him more of a
disruptive nuisance than a force of
destruction similar to Loki you have
scrummy r the master of illusion
also known as aught guard Loki a good
example of a destructive yotan is cert
or su tear the fire giant of Muspelheim
his only real purpose is to ensure that
the world burns during Ragnarok so that
a new one can be reborn and in this task
he is successful there is something
poetic about the world being created
from a giant of ice to then only be
destroyed by a giant of fire
if you do have any questions or you'd
just like to share your thoughts then
please do so in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology in
fiction explained
[Music]